on the reddit message boards people are
talking about how they'd love to hear
you do a history
podcast conan we might have mixed
feelings about that
and you just kind of moonlighting with
another podcast but other than that
does that is that something you'd be
interested in well first of all i'd like
to point out that they didn't say in
addition to
it could mean they want this one to end
oh no and they want something with a
little more fiber in it you know a
little more
protein i always go to the negative
right away and when someone says
hey you know what you'd be really good
at i think you mean i
you don't like the thing i'm doing now
that's an interesting concept
i am a history buff that's probably
uh come across during our ramblings
on the podcast the last couple of years
i uh also i'm a consumer of history
podcasts i've said this before but i
absolutely love dan carlin's
hardcore history uh and i recommend that
podcast it's one of my absolute
favorites
um that guy tells a great tale
and uh i've learned so much
from listening to dan carlin and then i
actually wrote him a
fan letter and i typed it
sona you know this i have an old kooky
typewriter and i typed him a
a fan letter and then uh
this is about two years ago and then i
think
like a month later i get this letter in
the mail
and it's from dan carlin and i'm jumping
around the kitchen going dan carlin
wrote me back
and my wife's like what is your problem
but the other one i've been listening to
recently is you know
i just took a long car trip with my kids
we didn't want to
fly we wanted to be safe so we took this
long car ride
and we were in the car together and we
started listening to this podcast
that's by a guy named mike duncan and
it's called revolutions
and this guy is
thorough he is very thorough
and i think the point i'm trying to make
is
uh um when people say hey conan you
should do a history podcast i've
listened to
real people that should be doing history
podcasts
like dan carlin and mike duncan and man
mike duncan
uh he did one on the
english civil war and
it's it gets so complicated and it's
fascinating
but there's like a whole bunch of
episodes explaining how
incredibly complicated it all was to the
point where i thought
can't just skip some stuff and just get
to the battles
but then he did one on the french
revolution and i'm listening to it
i've listened to 10 episodes
they're like 40 minutes each he hasn't
even gotten to the revolution yet
that's the title of the show and yeah
and uh but he really takes his time and
it's brilliant he's uh i give it up for
mike duncan i am not
dissing him in any way he's a brilliant
guy but man
very intelligent and he really knows his
stuff and i think
that's where i get intimidated that's
where i think i know some stuff about
history
and i can maybe shuck and jive and
bounce around and but it's not
going to be credible what era would you
start with
man that's a really good question let's
have a little taste before we say what
era would i start with
what about this look at my team
i've got sona who doesn't know about
anything that happened
no before in sync formed and then i've
got
gourley now i know you know some stuff
but you kind of know some stuff
this is my team so keep in mind whatever
podcast we do
it's going to be the three of us we're
doing a history podcast and we're going
to say
hey conan o'brien here today and uh we
are talking about the russian
revolution oh no quite an incredible
revolution i'm here
with my team of history experts sonam
obsession oh god
sona you know about the russian
revolution right they had a revolution
in russia was that a long time ago
yes well you know it's all relative but
yes it sort of broke out during
world war one okay many people say it
was a tottering regime and world war one
was going so badly that it pushed it
over the edge but yeah you know
1917 i think is a 1918 around then those
are russian revolution years
i uh stopped paying attention right
after you said world war one i'm so
sorry did you say
what what happened it was tottering i
heard the word tottering
yes yes okay uh see this is how it would
go now gourley you would jump in every
now and then
that's the one where they're all a bunch
of wooden dolls that lived inside each
other
exactly with the babushkas yes now we're
talking
what happened was in russia uh in the
uh early 20th century uh
basically everyone was for forced to
live inside of someone else
and they were all made of wood and so
this became now
that that's how it was for hundreds and
hundreds of years
but then as you get into the 20th
century and technology's improving
the little doll the smallest stall at
the ba you know
at the very center doesn't want to live
inside hundreds of thousands of other
dolls
and those other dolls don't want to live
inside and so the dolls start to rebel
and suddenly they burst open and all the
babushka dolls come out and they're
fighting with each other
okay yeah i'm loving this podcast i
think this is a green light
i want to know when the russian mail
order bride system started i'm more
interested in that than this like
revolution you're talking about well at
the time sona they used
telegraphs and so what would happen was
that they would post a picture
of a babushka lady made of wood and
uh someone in the united states would
see it in their local newspaper
and they'd send a telegraph and say i
like that babushka that one right there
send her to me i live in i live on
delancey street in sioux falls
i'm in closing four dollars in 15 cents
send the babushka doll to me and i will
have sex with
it
top of the charts apple podcast three
months running
yeah this you know the promise of the
podcast would be you'll know
less than you did before
this podcast will actively make you
stupid
so uh then of course rasputin
enters the scene oh he had a big dick
that's what i know about respiration
whoa
jesus didn't he that's the thing that i
know that's the kind of history i think
people are interested in is that he has
very large penis well that's never been
uh confirmed but it was a
uh a that was a rumor about rasputin who
was said to
uh rasputin of course the mad monk who
had the ear of the tsarina and many
people believe
uh helped alienate her even further from
the russian people and helped
uh foment the revolution many people
thought that that rasputin had to go and
in fact he was assassinated
but i i digress anyway yes big
probably big [ __ ] yeah wow that's right
up there with catherine the great
having a bunch of sex with horses have
you heard that no
yeah but that's not true well i'm sure
it's not true i don't know it's not just
hear about it
do you know catherine the great i've
talked to the horses the catherine the
great
died long ago but horses keep very good
records
i've read many horse diary from the
period and
they all say no didn't happen um and
we we take offense sounds like a bunch
of bitter horses that weren't selected
for the
big night yeah that could kill you yeah
having sex with a horse how could it not
kill you
i know you know what here's the thing
it's clear
it's clear what our history podcast
would be and if dan carlin's listening
or mike duncan my apologies or to anyone
in the true history community but this
is what my history podcast would be like
i would start the podcast
by saying uh of course harry s truman
uh was faced with a very uh difficult
decision
does he fire macarthur because he has
gone uh
north of the parallel line in korea
and incurred the wrath of the chinese
government or does he and then sona
would cut in
and go did macarthur have a big dick
and i'd go what and then the next thing
you know would be off and running
and maybe it would just mean that
it would be me trying the best i could i
think that's pretty good and i
i say to dan carlin and mike duncan step
it up a little
yeah you know do we need all that
information
right and also you can't talk about
rasputin without talking about his penis
because that's what
everybody knows about him or that song
you remember that song
rasputin lover of the russian queen
there was a cat who really was gone
is that the lyric yes well
that's this week's episode of big dick
history
we covered the russian revolution
babushka dolls living inside each other
rasputin
the old tripod as they called him
[Laughter]
next week milton berle and the rise of
vaudeville
next week milton berle the rise of
vaudeville
and then uh we'll be talking about a
scandal involving best
truman well you don't want to miss that
one